hi I'm Erik Bosse and Thor Ragnarok
might have been the most fun I've had in
a Marvel movie in a while but you know
the drill new rock stars can't just
leave it at that we got to sect the hell
out of this movie until we figure out
every reason why we love it it's just
like he did with all your toys as a kid
you know you break them down and lay out
all their parts like a psychopath
so let's rewatch Thor Wagner I can point
out all the subtle references to past
MCU movies and Marvel Comics as well as
the interesting design and tonal
influences that went into making this
film and spoiler warning if you haven't
seen Ragnarok yet just go watch it go on
piss off ghost and before I begin this
video was brought to you by Squarespace
whether you need a domain website or
online store make your next move with
Squarespace but more info on that later
let's get started okay right away with
the opening image notice how the Marvel
title cards holders and burns away at
vs. seems like a fun transition to
establish Thor in searchers fiery abode
but also this visual for shadows the
film's fiery Ragnarok end and vac this
whole opening scene is really great
about setting up the end in the
beginning notice how search her promises
Thor that he'll grow to the size of a
mountain and thrust his sword in the
Asgard and scores skeptically responsive
that would be a fun spectacle to see of
course this ends up being a promise and
a spectacle the film delivers in its
final sequence but obviously more on the
ending later that's not like this meta
boy's over from the Thor that opens the
movie there I know what you're thinking
how does this happen this actually
reminds me of the opening to another
third installment of an Avenger Iron Man
3 which remember opened in a similar
darkly funny way a famous man once said
we create our own demons who said that
what does that even mean
doesn't matter I said it cuz he said it
so now he was famous and basically
getting set by two well-known guys I
don't I'm gonna start again I think this
establishes these two three equals as
structural counterparts both movies
exile the Avenger away from the action
pairing them with a buddy in a source of
comic relief for most of the second act
and both movies end with the Avengers
home in ruins as they leave that world
behind in search of a new chapter also
in the same Thor and search are
introduced the idea of Ragnarok
obviously the title the movie Ragnarok
is the concept from Norse mythology it
translates to twilight of the gods it's
a cyclical doomsday type event where all
the gods die off including Odin and
their children take over beginning the
cycle anew this
was worked into the Thor comics coming
up repeatedly in serving as a subject of
Thor's Avengers disassembled comic in
2004 Thor attempts to prevent Ragnarok
by meeting with the gods to the gods
ultimately he allows himself and a scart
to be destroyed I'll get to the other
for comic influences as we go also I
love this joke of Thor having to wait
for mule near having miss time the
summoning you may recognize this as a
callback to the Avengers during his
fight with Hulk on the Helicarrier
[Music]
actually this could be a wink to these
two budding heads again in this movie
moving on to Asgard where Thor comes
upon Loki disguises Odin staging this
mock play now in case you missed it this
scene is a restaging of Loki's supposed
death in Thor the dark world even the
choral music from this choir is composer
Brian Taylor's funeral theme from that
movie
and yes Thor here is being played by a
cameo of Chris Hemsworth's brother Luke
Hemsworth remember he's in West's world
although Matt Damon cameos as Loki and
Sam Neill plays Odin you'll remember
Samuel from dressin Park with co-star
Jeff Goldblum in his movie he was also
in director tyka with TT's last movie
hunt for the wilderness now in this play
Loki apologizes for turning Thor into a
frog which is a reference to the Thor
comics by Walter Simonson which includes
a fraud version of Thor called frog he
carries a little hammer called Frog Jill
near yes it does sound like I just
pulled it out of my ass welcome to
comics by the way this move with Thor
holding Loki between his hand and hammer
is another detail pulled from the
Simonson brent of the comics it's
interesting here how Thor chastises Odin
/ Loki for the uprisings across the nine
realms kinda answers a question I've had
about this phase of the MCU like why
only now is Thanos coming to attack like
a I get it you just locked in an ass
groove on that throne and sanctuary but
you're a cosmic deity you'd have just
started that infinity stone hunt eons
ago here we learn how this cosmic unrest
is rising simultaneously with Odin's
coming death and we see how him going
into Odin sleep immediately unlocks the
gate for Hellas return similarly I think
Odin's protection was what kept Thanos
at bay
and now that he's gone with Ragnarok it
makes sense that all the gates are
unlocked for all kinds of evil powerful
tyrants to run amok including famous
okay moving on to New York
and this Shady Acres retirement home is
actually the same name of sinners and
South Park and Ace Ventura shows up a
lotta movies and notice how Thor has
disguised his hammer as an umbrella and
he taps it on the ground to transform
back into his true form now this is a
throwback reference to the early Thor
comics when he went by the alter ego of
Donald Blake and disguised his hammer as
a came that he could tap twice on the
ground to transform and it's interesting
how the exact scene between Thor and
Stephen strange that we saw in Doctor
Strange post-credits scene last year
plays fully in this movie the reason is
that once dr. strange had wrapped
production Taika Waititi was in a mad
rush to shoot his Ragnarok scenes in
this sanctum sanctorum set before it got
demolished or ragnaroks I guess you
could say so this scene wasn't shot as a
post-credit teaser it was always part of
the thor ragnarok movie they just lent
the footage to Doctor Strange since it
was shot so early and that way the
Doctor Strange team could remind general
audiences that strange is in fact hard
the Marvel world moving on to Norway now
you may have noticed that this first
fight with hella and the destruction of
Mjolnir was moved from the New York
alleyway that we saw in the first two
trailers to this field ytt we shot it
because he felt that the urban setting
wasn't right remember set photos also
showed Anthony Hopkins dressed as a
homeless person in New York so I think
this was a tonal adjustment like now
Odin gets this emotional send-off on
this cliffside in Norway the birthplace
of Norse mythology and then that would
lead to Hellas return which would take
place now in this nearby field ok let's
talk about hella played perfectly by
Kate Blanchet hella is Odin's first born
daughter in the movie and adaptation
from the comics where she's Loki's
daughter her design with the
form-fitting black green suit and
angular antlers is based on Jason
Aaron's comics Aaron is known for the
amazing god of thunder run which is a
huge influence on this movie
specifically in the comics is a
character named gore the god killer who
really rattles Thor the way hella does
in this movie or Gore Gore's Thor to the
core just some korg approved wordplay
for you and after the formalities notice
this simple demand hella jumps right to
Neil beg your pardon
before you Queen Loki's what reaction
here is deja vu to his conquering
arrival in the Avengers I've said
and after hella trails Thor and Loki to
the Bifrost and immediately kills two of
the Warriors three whom you care so
little about you probably don't even in
their names we see Thor crash-land on
the garbage planet of Sekar now Sekar is
from the planet hulk comics the other
major comic influence on this movie in
those hulk ends up on this planet after
destroying most of Vegas and being sent
away from earth by Nick Fury he ends up
fighting a gladiator style combat on
Sekar facing other contenders like the
Silver Surfer it's a great comic and
originally what CTU planned on simply
replacing Hulk width or in the Planet
Hulk storyline stranding him on this
battle planet like Mad Max and Beyond
Thunderdome or something luckily they
Rican see the movie as a buddy comedy
with both characters more on those
influences later we meet Valkyrie in
this scene in the Marvel Comics
Valkyries also known as Brunhilde and
she leads a Valkyrie or who carry the
souls of brave fallen soldiers back to
Valhalla and I guess in a way Valkyrie
does that for for in this movie
returning Thor to Asgard just making a
quick stop at the Grand Master's contest
two champions versus Thompson said that
she based her performance on Sarah
Connor from t2 Judgment Day which you
can kind of see in her independent
spirit and yeah heavy drinking her
costume here is modeled on Valkyries
look in the fearless defenders comic
though later she changes into a more
classic Silver Gold get up like her
armor from the 70's comics and I loved
the look of the planets a car the mix of
colors and shapes in the architecture
reflects the planets society as a
scavenger planet allowing other planets
to dump the scraps of their architecture
here for these residents to repurpose
and probably the biggest visual easter
egg was the Grand Master's tower which
contains the visages of past champions
all of whom are characters from the
comic the Greek god Ares man thing by
beast and beta ray bill now beta ray
bill is also from the Simonson run of
the comics he's a korbinite who at one
point wields mill near it's kind of a
another form of Thor
later on the comics too becomes one of
Thor's allies meanwhile back on Asgard
hello wipes out the entire Asgardian
defenses including Hogan yeah you didn't
know his name digit he was the last of
the warriors three apparently Kate
Blanchet trained in capoeira the
Brazilian martial art to be able to pull
off these awesome moves and back on
stack are the music that plays when Thor
is carted to the Grandmaster is pure
imagination you'll recognize that from
Willy Wonka the Chocolate Factory which
features a similar
Trippi trip through a tunnel that starts
off pleasant but then it gets weird and
terrifying and suddenly stops like
nothing happened and yes the true
oddball delight of this movie is Jeff
Goldblum's Grand Master it's just so
weird and awesome so nice of Goldblum do
improvises himself in this movie notice
the blue face paint on his chin that
could be a reference to the Grand
Master's full blue appearance in the
comics he is an elder the universe along
with the collector who is played by
Benicio del Toro in the guardians of the
galaxy in the movies these two our
brothers also notice that the Grand
Master calls his tournament the contest
of Champions which is a reference to the
Marvel Comics contest of Champions in
which the Grandmaster assembles various
other Marvel superheroes to fight each
other like he does here his assistant is
topaz played by Rachel House who also
worked with ytt and hunt for the wilded
people in the ultra horse comics topaz
is a warrior queen who also gets forced
by the Grandmaster to fight against the
Avengers there's a few other comic
references here grandmaster refers to
Valkyrie as scrapper number 142 which
could be a reference to Valkyries first
appearance in issue 142 of the Hulk
comics also this cousin Carlo whom the
Grandmaster melts is named after comic
book artist Carlo Pegu lion he worked on
the plan Hulk storyline and created the
character of Korg and a weird little
reference here maybe improvised
subconsciously by Goldblum was this line
this is strangely the same delivery and
gesture made by ray Fiennes and
Schindler's List this kind of makes a
Grand Master seem more menacing but
really it just seems like he's in his
own movie starring Jeff Goldblum now the
design of the Grand Master's suite here
and pretty much all the interiors of
Sekar drew heavily from Jack Kirby's art
in the comics Kirby was known for
angular cosmic LSD style imagery that
what TC mentioned as a heavy influence
in the look of this film specifically
noticed this guy who shows up in the
background of the grandmasters entourage
he has the same character design of a
celestial witch in the comics is a
god-like being that's thousands of feet
tall a real celestial actually showed up
in the collector's scene and guardians
of the galaxy now the Grandmaster mixes
techno music here which actually comes
up a lot in this cigar section in the
movie this was all composed by Mark
Mothersbaugh from the 80s electronica
band Devo
mother's boss said in an interview that
he wanted to give Ragnarok a distinct
sound after watching a video essay by
every frame of painting on the YouTube
on my favorite channels that criticized
the use
of forgettable temps scoring it past MCU
movies see it's not just haters here on
YouTube sometimes we can make a
difference to make car nerdy movies even
dirtier and I just love the little joke
here with Thor growling at Loki to free
him he's my brother
dog tease it's a great callback to one
of my favorite jokes and the Avengers
when Thor talked about Loki and he's my
brother
he killed 80 people in two days he's
adopted next we meet cord the other
hilarious scene stealer this movie Korg
was introduced in the Planet Hulk comics
he's a Crone in which are the rock
warriors remember Thor smashed one of
these guys to pebbles in the dark world
we also saw a Cronin briefly as an
easter egg and guardians of the galaxy
to earlier this year
now Korg is voiced by director Taika
Waititi who also did all the motion
capture for the role and part of what
makes him so funny is that what TC based
him on Polynesian nightclub bouncers
that he met in New Zealand whom he said
are physically huge but they had the
lightest and most delicate voices and
he's joined by make another warrior from
the Planet Hulk comics except here in
the movie they've changed his appearance
and gave him these awesome blade hands
okay check it back in on Asgard hella
and scourge tore Odin's throne room and
hella scoffs at the painting of Odin's
peace treaty with the frost giants which
is a callback to the prologue scene of
the first Thor when Odin defeated luffy
and right after this in the vault we get
a look at the casket of ancient winters
that they retrieved in that movie hella
calls it week and a really fun Easter
egg was hella shoving this gauntlet
calling it fake okay so just to explain
the background here in the first twenty
eleven Thor the Infinity Gauntlet
appeared as an easter egg in Odin's
vault but then later of course in the
post-credits scene of age of Ultron
Thanos appears with a gauntlet this led
to some confusion among fans over which
was the real gauntlet or if we're
supposed to pretend the one in the first
Thor didn't happen I mean what are we to
believe this is a magic gauntlet I guess
it is a magic Outlets I would drop my
question anyway thank you - hello for
clearing things up also she uses the
eternal flame to resurrect Fenris the
giant Asgardian wolf from the comics
back on Sekar before the battle chord
references a three pronged wooden weapon
saying it's not much use unless you want
to kill three vampires who were
clustered together this could be a
reference to what ETS previous film what
we do in the shadows which is about
three vampires who lived in close
quarters in a house together Stan Lee
makes his traditional cameo as the
barber who cuts Thor's hair now the idea
to cut Thor's signature long hair is an
interesting one apparently it came from
Chris Hemsworth himself along with the
choice to shatter me linear after hims
worth heard Kevin
criticized in the previous Thor movies
but also in ancient Roman history the
warrior slaves that were put in
gladiator training had their hair cut
short which could be an influence here
also notice how hoaxes hair appears
shorter in this movie than it did in
past film so apparently all the
gladiators go through this although I
don't really picture a whole letting
anyone get close to his head with
scissors even if they're Stanley now the
match between Thor and Hulk has a ton of
great details first the shield that Thor
picked out seems to have an interesting
color scheme here red stripes in a blue
circular centre it's possible that he
picked that out because it reminded them
of Captain America shield
no no also look closely the background
of the grandmasters box that is more
Jack Kirby artwork it's literally a
color version of the century sinister
cover of the Fantastic Four issues
number 64 and when Hulk smashes his way
into the arena his armor and Spartan
style helmet is the same design as his
appearance in the Planet Hulk comics and
Chris Hemsworth's great line here from
work that was a line suggested by a kid
from the make-a-wish Foundation who is
visiting set that day now I really loved
how this movie as a whole both paid
homage to past MCU movies while also
poking fun at them specifically with
Thor trying to calm Hulk by reciting hey
big guy the Suns getting real low and it
stroking his palm this of course is a
callback to the you cofee ritual between
Hulk of Black Widow and age of Ultron
hey big guy Suns getting real low
but with perfect comedic precision the
scene undercuts this moment with another
callback Hulk thrashing Thor like a rag
doll just like he did with Loki and
Avengers explaining why look II was so
stressed out this whole scene later in
Hulk's apartment this movie shifts into
more of a buddy comedy between these two
Avengers yct mentioned his influences
movies like Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid Midnight Run and planes
trains and automobiles he also singled
out Big Trouble in Little China with the
character of Jack Burton being a big
influence on Thor in this movie the
director asked what's the version of
Thor just wanting to get his truck back
he's the one looking at the world and
bring in a certain sarcasm and irony to
this cosmic landscape another fun detail
check out how a hoax bed frame is a
giant jawbone probably a nod to some
massive creature he killed maybe also
foreshadowing him jumping towards
Searchers massive open mouth at the end
of the movie huh read into things yeah
okay I also like how Hulk wears this
beaded necklace like he does in the
Ultimate Thor comics and then Valkyrie
gives Thor the amount of time it'll take
her to drink some booze to explain his
issue but then she Chuck's it matter of
seconds she's a nice parallel to Thor's
chugging skills and we saw him in the
Doctor Strange scene earlier yes as
cardis just won't have time to nurse
their drinks brah later when Thor tries
to access Tony Stark's Quinn jet he
tries to the password strongest Avenger
knows obviously that's whole cuz we find
out later
eventually he gets it right with Point
Break which is a reference to Thor's
surfer hair and Starks nickname for him
in the Avengers no hard feelings Point
Break you got a mean swing also this
video transmission for Black Widow it's
the same recording that she left for
Bruce at the end of age of Ultron which
Hulk cut off oh hang up but this time it
works
turning Hulk back into Bruce Banner who
then covers himself with Tony Stark's
spare clothes including this Duran Duran
shirt it's a cover of their album REO
which includes a song hungry like a wolf
perhaps a loose set up for a Hulk
fighting Fenris later and during this
section we also get this interesting
shot of Loki and Valkyrie walking up to
the Grand Master where the camera swoops
through the mirrored surface creating an
optical illusion where their reflections
are actually the subject of the action
this reminded me a lot of the famously
impossible shot in the movie contact
where a director Robert Zemeckis move
the camera up the stairs and down the
hallway before revealing but this is all
somehow in the reflection of a mirror
now do I think what TT is intentionally
paying homage to Zemeckis here I don't
know the movies do both contain
similarly trippy travels through
wormholes really I could just see what
easy wanting to embrace some of the more
complex and memorable
Jools from recent sci-fi film and
speaking of sci-fi ytp actually
consulted with a real-life theoretical
physicist Clifford Johnson on the space
travel in the script you actually see
some of that influence in the scene
where banner describes The Devil's anus
wormhole as an einstein-rosen bridge now
an einstein-rosen bridge is a concept in
astrophysics that describes wormholes as
the bending of space-time taking the
shape of two exterior regions connected
by a tube Thank You Wikipedia also by
the way Valkyrie proposes in this scene
to travel through Zangara to get back to
Asgard which of course is a reference to
the planet and guardians of the galaxy
now Thor and Loki using their get helped
trick is one of my favorite bits in the
movie and a breakdown he did of the seen
what TTT pointed out how physical comedy
tends to work better in a wide shot
which is why we see Hemsworth a Hillston
and wide when the elevator opens also
notice how after the throw Loki pops
back up into frame as Thor just
continues to walk forward smiling watch
easy said that keeping the action moving
makes the scene funnier than like
cutting the Loki on the ground well
since he also pointed out this one
spaceship in the background here taking
great pride and having designed it
himself I haven't been acknowledged my
amazing design which is essentially a
box a flying box and nobody's done that
before in the movies sit for me now
another interesting detail the names of
the various ships in this movie include
the Commodore tirana statesman in
Kingswood these are all names of
real-life models of the Australian car
company Holden and jumping forward to
this final battle on Asgard van are
jumping out of the ship and landing hard
on the bridge still as banner is yeah
hilarious it's also kind of a nod to the
fall in the 2008 Hulk except it's
funnier this time
and when Hulk joins a battle in its full
god of thunder form Led Zeppelin's
immigrant song kicks back in this song
is so perfect for a Thor movie I'm kind
of shocked that it hasn't been used in
one of these movies before Robert
Plant's lyrics include words like hammer
of the gods and Valhalla I am coming and
you really can't get more on the nose
for Thor than that also in past videos I
pointed out how plants opening Banshee
whale may have inspired similar badass
melodies over the years notably the
recent Wonder Woman theme in Diana's
thunderous arrival in Batman V Superman
that Thema vocht a similar feeling of
power that plants voice gives the god of
thunder here
[Music]
but take it easy Marvel vs. DC front
liners I'm not saying anyone is ripping
off anyone else here it's just that
certain melodies can leave you to what
to depict your powerful hero and the
similar best light meanwhile down in
Odin's vault
Loki pauses on the tesseract now it's
pretty heavily implied that he stole it
here and I have more theories on what
he's gonna do with it and I break down
to the post-credits scene so make sure
to go check that out now back in the
battle scourge redeems himself by using
his twin machineguns
deaths and Troy to fend off Hellas army
and allow the s guardians to escape now
this is a direct homage to scourge his
last stand in the comics when he stood
alone at gala brew sacrificing himself
so that others could escape now I don't
know about you guys but I gotta hand it
to what CT for having the balls to end
Ragnarok by literally burning it all
down delivering on Searchers promise to
plunge a sword in Asgard to destroy us
who me this is a key part of what makes
Ragnarok stand out from every other MCU
movie even the really good ones like the
Guardians movies or the first Avengers
or Doctor Strange they still always end
with the heroes preventing doomsday but
here what TV says screw all that you
said in interviews that he wanted to
approach this the Ragnarok way full out
heading for the fire sprinting full
speed toward Armageddon so yeah it's in
a lot of ways super satisfying to see
Asgard get destroyed it almost feels
like with TT drew on the finales of
movies like the cabin in the woods or
this is the end comically embracing the
end of days with this giant fire demon
but as you're watching this movie you
can't help but be reminded of Douglas
Adams The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy which opens with the earth
getting obliterated and if you saw it
Edgar Wright's amazing the World's End
which has a similar apocalyptic scenario
and it's precisely because all of these
movies chose to have a not so precious
attitude toward the stakes they're more
about the absurdist comedy and the ways
these characters have to adapt to these
changes and the fun that we should all
have with such a weird cosmic adventure
which character did you find to be the
most fun to watch in Ragnarok and why is
it a tie between Grand Master and Court
comment down below and tweet me your
thoughts at da boss or follow new
rockstars on twitter at new rockstars
for updates on their videos as i
mentioned before this video was
sponsored by Squarespace with
Squarespace you can build a super
stylish website fast and make your next
move and setting up a business launching
a creative project or just posting
various pictures of your head
photoshopped in the
the North Scott they had professionally
designed templates that look great and
intuitive tools to make it so easy even
if you don't know anything about coding
check it out this is a site that I put
together very quickly it's great start
your free trial today at squarespace.com
and go to Squarespace comm slash new
rockstars to get 10% off your first
purchase or click on the link in the
description below and of course like and
share this video and subscribe to new
rock stars for all of our deep dives in
a Marvel and other stuff that you love
and if you really want to be part of our
team you can contribute to us on patreon
big thanks to all of our donors
especially Allen Fleming
thanks for watching